sie gaben sich in moskau die klinke in
die hand und ließen sich von putins
propaganda benutzen wir haben ein
strategisches interesse daran gute
beziehung zu russland zu haben
russlands präsident konnte die krim
annektieren gegner ermorden lassen oder
ins straflager sperren
probiert wurde er trotzdem von
selbsternannten kennern des russischen
präsidenten ich meine russland das ist
ja relativ deutlich haben faktisch kein
interesse daran in der ukraine
einzumarschieren natürlich nicht der
krieg gegen die ukraine hat deutschlands
putin verstehe von links bis rechts kalt
erwischt
ich glaube dass es über all die jahre
wichtig ist gespräche zu suchen
wir dürfen gerade in diesen tagen
russlands beitrag für deutschland und
europa eben nicht vergessen
[Musik]
berlin siebzehnter märz stehender
applaus für den ukrainischen präsidenten
wolodimir seelands
nur ein abgeordneter bleibt zunächst
sitzen und rührt auch später keine hand
robert fahle von der afg
schale wirft deutschen medien drei
wochen nach kriegsbeginn einen
propagandakrieg gegen putin vor auf
seinem youtube kanal den mädchen war die
letzten zwei jahren vor allen dingen
eine art panikmache betrieben haben
wollen uns jetzt in einen konflikt gegen
russland
putin zumal ein jäger und kriegstreiber
dann zu stellen reicht als erklärung für
diesen komplexen konflikt überhaupt
nicht aus
die treusten putin freunde ganz weit
rechts afg chef kruppa im dezember 2020
in moskau der kreml lobt ihn für sein
zitat wichtigen besuch bei russlands
außenminister
nach kriegsbeginn solidarisiert sich der
bundestag mit der ukraine afd stimmt
dagegen
[Applaus]
es darf in diesen tagen aber nicht unser
ziel sein den einen schuldigen
auszumachen wir dürfen gerade in diesen
tagen
russlands beitrag für deutschland und
europa eben nicht vergessen die russland
nähe der afg hat tradition ein beispiel
markus hohlmeier
bundestagsabgeordneter
2018 lässt er sich auf die krim einladen
und rechtfertigt im russischen
staatsfernsehen putins annexion der
halbinsel
es ist nun mal so dass die krim jetzt
die russische grimm ist daran werden
auch die leute die das sehr kritisch
begleiten nichts mehr ändern können die
grünen kommen nicht mehr zurück
moskau vor frohnmeyer wahl in den
bundestag 2017 entwickelt ein duma
mitarbeiter konkrete pläne für den
jungen afd politiker
peter prämie ein früherer kgb-offizier
will frohnmeyer für russische zwecke
einsetzen prämie schreibt in einer
e-mail
kandidat markus frohnmeyer
notwendig unterstützung im wahlkampf
ergebnis im bundestag wird es einen
abgeordneten geben der zu uns gehört und
den wir absolut unter kontrolle haben
frohnmeyer unter kontrolle der russen
der bestreitet die vorwürfe
im märz 2018 sind frohnmeyer und weitere
afd politiker wieder in russland als
wahlbeobachter auf einladung des kremls
frohnmeyer twittert
wir machen uns ein bild davon dass alles
fair und demokratisch abläuft und sind
vor ort
auch der berliner fdp-abgeordnete gunnar
lindemann fühlt sich berufen als
wahlbeobachter
2018 fährt er auf einladung der
separatisten nach den jetzt zu
manipulierten wahlen die ein
prorussische regime legitimieren sollen
die wahllokale die ich besucht habe
ist die wahl aus meiner sicht
vernünftig und ordnungsgemäß abgelaufen
es konnten alle menschen wählen egal ob
sido letzter pässe hatten egal ob die
ukraine besser hatten auch nach
kriegsbeginn ändert lindemann seinen pro
russischen standpunkt nicht
westen und ukraine sind schuld dass es
eskaliert haben ostern ist schuld dass
es einmarschierte im prinzip sind alle
beteiligten schuld
er nannte putin ein freund und
lupenreinen demokraten er durfte zwei
russische kinder adoptieren seit jahren
arbeitet er für russische
energiekonzerne wie rosneft und gazprom
bei wladimir putin steht gerhard
schröder in der ersten reihe
der altkanzler soll beim russischen
präsidenten im ukraine krieg vermittelt
haben einziger hinweis ein trost von
schröders frau aus moskau in wessen
auftrag schröder unterwegs war unbekannt
[Musik]
meines erachtens ist das eine aktion
allein in eigener sache gerhard schröder
hat die allergrößte angst dass er hier
in deutschland zur persona non grata
wird dass er als mensch der sich
derartig zum angestellten eines
diktators gemacht hat und sich nicht bis
heute distanziert hat übrigens auch bis
heute nicht von seinen wirtschaftlichen
verflechtungen dass er als solcher
seinen ruf in deutschland endgültig
ramponiert hat
nach kriegsbeginn empfiehlt
bundeskanzler olaf scholz seinem
parteifreund die lukrativen posten in
russland aufzugeben da steht schröders
mitgliedschaft in der spd bereits zur
diskussion
ich finde es nicht richtig dass gerd
schröder diese ämter wahrnimmt und ich
glaube auch dass es richtig wäre er
würde sie niederlegen ob es der spd
schadet wo jeder weiß dass wir damit
nicht einverstanden sind das weiß ich
nicht das hoffe ich nicht und das glaube
ich auch nicht aber an meinen rat an
gerd schröder ist doch sich aus diesen
ämtern zurückzuziehen
kurz darauf wird die spd deutlicher die
parteispitze fordert in einem brandbrief
von schröder
handle und sage klare worte
mehrere spd verbände beantragen
schröders parteiausschluss der hält an
seinem posten fest selbst als der
ukrainische botschafter bekannt gibt
dass friedensverhandlungen mit putin
seien gescheitert
ist gerhard schröder jetzt oder
jedenfalls in kürzester zeit da sich
herausgestellt haben wird dass er nichts
erreicht hat ist er dann bereits seine
aufgaben seine dienste seinen teuer
bezahlten dienst zu verbreiten wir putin
einzustellen das ist die entscheidende
frage und bis dato gibt es noch keine
anhaltspunkte dass gerhard schröder auch
bereit ist ökonomische konsequenzen zu
ziehen denn der krieg geht unvermindert
weiter
schröder gibt derweil seine
ehrenbürgerwürde in hannover ab und
kommt der stadt damit nur zuvor
ich verzichte unwiderruflich auf die
ehrenbürgerwürde der stadt hannover
das dilemma der spd bleibt
denn die ostpolitik willy brandts und
wandel durch handel sind mit putin
gescheitert
doch an der deutsch russischen
freundschaft wollten viele in der spd
lange festhalten ich glaube dass es
gerade wichtig ist in schwierigen zeiten
im dialog zu bleiben blumen für den
russischen botschafter
nord stream 2 war ihr projekt russisches
gas für deutschland
ministerpräsidentin schwesig gründete
gar eine landesstiftung die half
us-sanktionen gegen nord stream zwei zu
umgehen finanziert vom russischen
konzern gazprom bis zum schluss sogar
noch bis in die neue regierung in einer
hat mal gesprochen nord stream zwei sei
ein privates kommerzielles projekt das
ist ein einfach einfach falsch um nicht
ein schärferes wort zu gebrauchen
nach kriegsbeginn vollziehen auch die
letzten genossen die 180 grad russland
wende nord stream 2 gestoppt die
mitarbeiter entlassen und
schwesigs regierungssitz r leuchtet in
den farben der ukraine
[Musik]
16 jahre lang hat angela merkel
deutschland geführt und putin wenig
entgegengesetzt der nutzte die schwäche
aus
2007 merkel für ihre angst vor hunden
bekannt vorgeführt vom russischen
präsidenten
trotzdem hält merkel fest an putin und
an öl und gas aus russland wir setzen
auf einen zuverlässigen lieferanten
russland sie unterstützt den bau von
nord stream 2 das geht so bis zum ende
ihrer kanzlerschaft
[Applaus]
liebesgrüße aus moskau die sendet auch
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
voller stolz im januar 2020 via facebook
nach hause
zum einen ging es um die zusammenarbeit
zwischen bayern und moskau und russland
insbesondere im wirtschaftlichen bereich
wie denkt markus söder heute über seinen
besuch bei putin für ein interview hat
er keine zeit bei einem
weißwurstfrühstück mit us soldaten
fragen wir nach und söder rechtfertigt
sich nicht er habe um den besuch bei
putin gebeten sondern eine einladung
erhalten ich habe lange überlegt ob ich
die dann im frühjahr 2020 das war noch
vor krone annehmen soll habe damals
gespräche geführt unter anderem in der
bundeskanzlerin gefragt
soll man das machen denn es gab damals
schon eine reihe von fragen ich glaube
dass es über all die jahre richtig ist
gespräche zu suchen auch jetzt ist das
sinnvoll gespräche zu suchen gespräche
suchte auch horst seehofer der kreml
nutzte es für propaganda im jahr zwei
der krim annexion kündigt das russische
staatsfernsehen
seehofer als gegner von russland
sanktionen an
dankbar dass hier heute erklären ließen
dass wir nicht als verschwörer kommt
delegationsmitglied edmund stoiber feld
putin um den hals die reaktion schon
damals verheerend
dass erde ist nur dass solche leute wie
stoiber und wie sie alle heißen sie
können es nicht bei einem formellen
handschlag wie es sich gehört belassen
sondern sie müssen ihm gleich die hand
auf die schulter legen oder sich umarmen
lassen und das zeigt in gewisser weise
auch den verfall der politischen und
diplomatischen form
sachsens ministerpräsident michael
kretschmer cdu fährt im april 2021 nach
moskau kurz nach der festnahme von kreml
kritiker alexej nawalny
kretzschmar kostet von seinem moskauer
hotel sofa aus telefonierte gerade mit
putin
kretzschmar verteidigt später die sofas
zähne und glaubt weiterhin an dialog der
presse bestätigt kretzschmar beim
gespräch habe er sich gegen russland
sanktionen ausgesprochen
wenn es nach mir ginge würde ich sie
sofort abschaffen
[Musik]
ich meine russland das ist ja relativ
deutlich haben faktisch kein interesse
daran in der ukraine einzumarschieren
natürlich nicht vier tage später
geschieht das was viele in der linken
ausgeschlossen hatten putin überfällt
die ukraine
die linke bundestagsabgeordnete sevim
dagdelen verunglimpfte sorgen über einen
angriffskrieg als erfindung des us
geheimdienstes
sie erzählen eine lüge von einem
russischen anderes krieg einer invasion
das ist doch wirklich eine
informationspolitik die uns darin leiten
soll zu glauben dass der russe den krieg
will und der aggressor ist die russland
versteher in der linken geben sich nach
kriegsbeginn plötzlich geläutert
[Musik]
dass putin so weit gehen würde dass das
passieren würde was jetzt passiert ist
habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt so nicht
vorstellen können so einfach geht s
nicht ja man kann nicht 20 oder wie
viele jahre verständnis innig die putins
gewaltpolitik interpretieren und
russland versteher heißt ja eigentlich
dass man etwas versteht von russland und
es wäre gut gewesen sozusagen den mund
zu halten von dingen von denen man
nichts versteht der linke
bundestagsabgeordnete
andrej hunko will sich äußern noch am 12
februar 2022 steht linken-politiker
hunko die ukraine als aggressor dar
[Musik]
niemand geht von einem einmarsch
russlands in die ukraine aus die
medienberichte im westen lösen er
erstaunen aus ich glaube auch dass das
auch realistisch war weil die ich glaube
auch sehr viele menschen in russland
selbst sind überrascht von dem einmarsch
im chor ist der 2015 ein jahr nach der
annexion der krim und der besetzung des
dollars in die ost ukraine
er brachte damals hilfsgüter in die
region
gleichzeitig posierte er in der
selbsternannten volksrepublik dann jetzt
mit separatistenführer alexander
kravchenko
um q erklärt das foto so er habe vor ort
kooperieren müssen
fehler
vielleicht hätte man keine fotos machen
sollen ich glaube es war richtig sich
überhaupt mal die andere seite
anzuschauen auch nach dem einmarsch
russlands in die ukraine sehen genossen
wie hunko eine mitschuld des westens für
diesen einmal trägt putin die
verantwortung aber
das scheitern einer eines
gesamteuropäischen
sicherheitssystems und stattdessen die
nato immer weiter auszudehnen das ist in
der tat eine mitverantwortung und viele
experten haben davor gewarnt die linke
in der nato frage zerrissen
erste mitglieder verlassen die partei
gregor gysi meldet sich per brief zu
wort schreibt an wagenknecht hunko und
co
ihr seid nur daran interessiert eure
alte ideologie zu retten die nato ist
böse die usa sind böse die
bundesregierung ist böse in einer video
botschaft wendet sich gysi an russische
volk und verfällt nach wenigen minuten
in alte rhetorik über
[Musik]
jahre wollten deutsche politiker von
links bis rechts putin verstehen und
haben sich getäuscht für gute
wirtschaftsbeziehungen ließen sie putin
gewähren der überschritt eine rote linie
nach der anderen bis hin zum krieg
[Musik]